all right we're live we're at the spin
room at the Ronald Reagan Presidential
Library joining us now former Ambassador
former governor of the great state of
South Carolina Nikki Haley is with us
Governor good to see you how are you you
prefer Governor right I don't always get
that Nikki those are Nikki okay you're
very nice to say that you know it's
interesting moment I just asked for
vague about the moment you had with him
every time I hear you I feel Dumber we
can't trust you Vivek
wow that was a pretty pretty powerful
shot why because you look at the fact
that he was in business with a Chinese
company to make Chinese medicines not
with an American company to make
American medicines a Chinese company to
make Chinese medicines then you go and
you look at the family he was doing
business with and he turns around and is
in business with the family that gave
Hunter Biden five million dollars and
then he wants to suddenly go and promote
Tick Tock I don't trust it I don't trust
it everything
I don't trust it either no but
everything all of this was Chinese
Communist Party related so how do we
trust it and then he suddenly decides
not to be in business the second before
he decides to run for president it
smells bad I don't appreciate it we've
got a country to save I don't trust it I
cannot understand about this President
they lie to us and say the borders
closed the borders secure our our eyes
do not deceive us but they continue to
lie but I trust the American and how
does China get away with oh let's see a
spy balloon flying all across the
continental U.S over our military
installation why do we let them buy
thousands and thousands of Acres of
farmland and Ranch Land why are they
confronting our mil of our air force in
international you know Airways that are
navy and international waterways and
there are no consequences why I I mean
look I mean this was the whole issue
that I have with President Trump he was
great on trade he never held them
accountable for covid he never did
anything about the fentanyl coming
across he didn't stop them buying Our
Land There was a Chinese spy Base in
Cuba he didn't do anything about that
this is our number one yeah
he did get for the first time that I
think I know of in history
he certainly had them pay their fair
share when it came to trade unfair trade
we didn't do National Security and our
farmers are paying for it and we're
seeing it with all the intrusion that
we're seeing in America that should have
been stopped years ago and he didn't do
it on top of that he congratulated the
Chinese Communist party on their 70th
Anniversary you can't be nice to people
like that these guys want to destroy
America they are planning war with
America we have to start being strong
and tough with them and let them know
they can't kill Americans anymore yeah
uh Governor they're telling me I think
we appreciate you being with us uh great
job tonight I hope you had fun thanks
it's always a beautiful place to have a
debate I'll say that absolutely go to
nikkihaley.com and join us all right
Governor thank you we appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else